foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS of moving and storage
Studios it's the Ramsay show where debt
is dumb Cassius king and the paid off
Home Mortgage has taken the place of the
BMW as the status symbol of choice
we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today open phones here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
thank you for joining us America
our latest numbers reveal that there's
about 22 million of you out there thank
you so much we're honored we appreciate
that we are here to serve you triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Mark is with us in Knoxville hey Mark
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave how you doing better than we
deserve sir how can we help
I am self-employed I'm the only employee
I have been for about 25 years always
filed a sole proprietor and my brother
is telling me I need to switch to C Corp
but I'll save money but he can't really
explain to me why and when I tried to
look it up I don't know if I can since
it's just me with no employees so is it
something I can do and if so should I do
it you can do it and you should not do
it and you should not take any more
accounting advice from your brother
okay okay now if you do want to the only
reason for a sole proprietor like
yourself to incorporate or to open an
LLC would be to risk manage meaning uh
what do you do what kind of business is
it
it's auto detailing okay so if um
if you're if someone was walking past uh
where you were auto detailing they
tripped over the hose and broke their
face okay and they said oh this guy
looks Rich we're going to sue him
well you have two options in uh number
one you'd have insurance that would pay
him for his broken face because it was
your fault his hose your hoes tripped
him I guess I don't know how the world
works today but I reckon that's how it
happens right and um the second thing is
if your business assets the things that
your business owns
are owned by an LLC a limited liability
company or a sub S corporation the only
person that they could sue would be the
company that owned the hose
which isn't you it's your company your
company's assets consist of your tools
probably
right and whatever cash you have in the
company checking account so they could
sue you and get all of that stuff but
they couldn't come after your personal
home your personal checking account
because it wasn't you that owned the
hoes that tripped them it was this
company over here that you own
okay so it's it's what we it's what we
call risk management there's no tax
benefit at all
for a sub s or an LLC because 100 of
your profits pass straight through and
land on your personal return and you get
taxed on in exactly the same way you
would if you didn't have this and you
can write off uh your business expenses
as a sole proprietor exactly the same
way
um
personally what I would tell you to do
is talk to your insurance broker get a
good business insurance policy that
covers some liability if someone tripped
over your hose and I wouldn't bother to
incorporate the reason I wouldn't is
it's going to cost you to incorporate or
to build the LLC and then you've got to
file a tax return on that entity every
year in addition to your own tax returns
so you get this bill from your tax
preparer for producing this the only
reason you would want to do this is if
you have a large Target on your butt now
are you worth over a million dollars
personally
no Okay then if somebody might want to
come out find some excuse to come after
you then you'd have a Target on your
butt then you might want to do this but
your business isn't of enough size that
somebody's probably going to go lick
their chops and go oh I'm about to get
rich here
okay and Mark I have general liability
business insurance
what you're talking about but he's
trying to he's saying is that he he was
also a sole proprietor but he switched
to the C Corp because he says it's going
to save him money something to do with
social security or something I don't
know exactly you can you can write off
the Social Security portion as an
expense that is an addition and you do
that with a sub S as well a C Corp you
get taxed twice
the corporation pays taxes and then when
it pays you you pay taxes again so a C
Corp is asinine for a small business
holder because you a small business
owner because you get taxed twice I've
got uh a bazillion llc's uh and I have
one S Corp I don't own a single
C Corp and I don't
um uh and I don't own anything anymore
everything is now in some entity's name
other than mine even my cars are in
something else's name I don't actually
personally own anything because I'm a
walking Target
I see and so you're saying that I should
either do c uh S Corp just to have the
liability exactly savings or just stay
where I'm at with my general liability
insurance or if and you can he's
actually right you can write off the
portion of a portion of your Social
Security as a business expense but it
amounts to you know it's not gonna It's
Not Gonna Save you enough in taxes to
pay you back for the attorney fees to
build the stupid thing or your tax
preparer fees to file the extra filing
every year it isn't worth it
I I okay you know I wouldn't do it
you've got uh 99 of the same write-offs
that an S corp has I I wouldn't fool
with it I you know I don't think you've
got the risk management issue and there
is no write-off issue and c-corps are
double tax no never do that the only
time you do a C Corp is if you're
building something to take it public and
sell it to some other big Corporation or
something there might be some advantages
then but for the normal person like you
and me operating our own small business
no way never a C Corp
and just stay so proprietor keep up my
general liability insurance and just
leave it like it is that's what I do I
keep your life Simple Man
okay that's all right that's what I
needed yeah good question thank you for
calling in this comes up a lot with the
Ontario leadership group the small
business folks that we coach and counsel
all the time we hear this same thing
that comes up everybody's looking for
some kind of tax Dodge and they think
that the rich have some tax Dodge that
regular people don't have and they don't
that is good to know and I think it's
interesting that his brother brought
this up after he's been in business for
25 years like Mark's been doing a good
job keeping up with everything and
following through and it was very
interesting that his brother felt that
now was the important time to have an
opinion yeah well there's yeah
yeah
it's you know the only so the the if
your business is small you would never
do it number one if you're uh in unless
you have a large
thing so for instance let's say you're
worth two million dollars and
um you decide you want to open an art
studio well you might want to put an LLC
over that because again if somebody
trips on the threshold Falls or whatever
whatever the scenario is that somebody
decides they're going to sue you
um and everybody's you know not
everybody but too many people in our
litigious Society are looking for a free
ride or a free ticket
and you just gotta do risk management
protect yourself as you start Building
Wealth
the other thing you can do guys once you
get to on liability issues once you get
up over a half million to a million
dollar net worth you can pick up a an
umbrella policy for about 300 bucks a
year for a million dollars and it covers
that much more this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I pretty much went to Christmas year
round I love Christmas I love Christmas
time Traditions we've got an awesome
Christmas tradition here at Ramsey we do
the Ramsey Christmas Cash giveaway yep
all month long all the way up until
Christmas you can enter to win one of
our weekly 500 prizes or the five
thousand dollar grand prize go to
ramseysolutions.com giveaway you can
enter every day to increase your chances
to win of course no purchase necessary
and of course you got to be 18 to win
that's ramseysolutions.com giveaway and
good news for your Christmas budget the
ten dollar sale is back yup inflation
did not get at us
not yet if you're crushing your goals
and changing your family tree this is a
great time to share your experience and
gift The Total Money Makeover to a
friend this is our biggest ten dollar
sale yet some of the new titles include
baby steps millionaires Ken Coleman's
from paycheck to purpose and questions
for humans conversation cards from Dr
John deloney something for everybody
everybody on the Christmas list make a
list check it twice could be ten dollars
check it out
ramseysolutions.com I like the Costco
hot dogs our prices aren't going up oh
there you go we're in the big time right
there with the Costco hot dogs if you're
there you're in Tall Cotton I'm just
saying all right Christina Ellis Ramsey
personality is my co-host today rickette
is with us rickette is in Phoenix hey
rickette how are you
I'm good how are you better than we
deserve what's up
so Dave I have a question for you I am
debt free I listen to your book followed
the instructions and I have become debt
free that needs my cars to the loans the
whole shebang way to go kiddo yes that
income ratio is zero I owe nobody
nothing but my dilemma is now I feel
like I probably missed the race of me
purchasing a home like I I this would be
like my first time ever purchasing a
home and so my question to you Dave is I
know interest rates are up prices are
somewhat going down for home should I
should I buy like what should I do
because I mean
I don't I don't know what I should do
right now
I want to buy a home I feel like I'm
ready to buy a home my credit score is 8
10. my debt to income ratio is zero and
why would you're not ready to purchase
why would you not because everybody is
saying that the interest rates are you
know it's the housing prices are too
they're too high which means my mortgage
would be too much have you noticed that
everybody is stupid
please
you notice that yeah yeah
everybody's in debt not Rickett
very true do you have a down payment
saved up
I have about like
um well total my savings I have like 50
000 like completely saved okay not
including That's not including
um my pension you know I work for the
um I work for the state a government job
so I've been here for like five years so
you leave your emergency fund out of
that and you put the rest of it down and
you can do a 15-year fix where the
payment's no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay then I wouldn't hesitate
to tell you to buy uh your Phoenix
Market had shot up and has adjusted down
it is one of the a handful of markets
that have adjusted down the rest of them
have just slowed their growth rate
that you're not going to see a market
like 2008 where Phoenix prices go down
substantially you're just not going to
see it there's too much demand
okay and if you buy with high interest
rates and interest rates go down what do
you do
you say that ding ding you get the prize
and I think it's just important that you
still get a house that you can afford I
feel like a lot of people in this market
assume you know if they are going to go
in then they got to go push up their
monthly payment a little bit more or
something like that but still look at a
house that you know brings your monthly
payment to a quarter of your take-home
pay or below make sure you're still
reasonable and thoughtful as you go
through it because I think the fear can
do both things that can make you either
stay out of the market or go a little
crazy and try to justify some purchase
that you shouldn't make we've had
several people call in and say you know
we we got a house but you know the
Market's so crazy and we look at the
numbers and it's 40 of their take-home
pay don't do that like still be
reasonable still use wise decision
making in it but if you have you know no
debt if you have a down payment and
you're ready to buy and you find a house
you can afford then still go for it yeah
exactly I think it's a really good point
just because people in Washington are
stupid just because they've gone crazy
just because inflation's going crazy
doesn't mean you need to go crazy
because guess what they're still going
to be crazy while you're being broke
because you did something stupid so
don't just go I won't I you know I don't
have to worry about math anymore because
there's inflation math doesn't count
this year we get a year off from math no
you get math in California in Manhattan
and in Nashville you get math everywhere
you go and math is going to kick your
butt when you buy something you can't
afford and you use all of your emotions
to justify Christine is exactly right
this is the deal all right Penelope is
with us in Little Rock hi Penelope
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave thanks so much
um I am on the stepson I paid off my
house sort of mid-september of last year
but my credit score has not gone to zero
it's hovering in sort of the 647 area
and I'm obviously excited for it to get
a zero I was wondering you should it be
there by now or is there something else
I could do to make it go to zero
well it doesn't matter because you're
not gonna be borrowing money but it is a
it's just something we want to see
happen here I don't disagree with you so
the deal that we what we understand now
listen FICO they run their deal and they
keep their algorithm they keep their
formula under lock and key so no one
knows for sure but all we've been able
to do is observe Ramsay followers that
when they have 100 of their accounts
closed down zero balance no activity no
outstanding bad credit nothing on the
bureau it's squeaky clean when you pull
up all three of your Credit Bureau
reports you go to Experian you go to
everybody you look at every one of them
and you make sure there's not a single
thing showing up not any uh Eight dollar
water bill from eight years ago that you
forgot was on there that'll keep it down
there at 600. you know it's got you got
to have it
100 clean usually in six six months to
nine months it's gone if you're 100 zero
balances no activity on the account
yeah that's what I thought too I've had
some soft inquiries from you know like
insurance companies and you know just
stuff like that but other than that yeah
and all closed accounts and yeah no
activity you can put marketing blocks on
and keep the soft inquiries down uh but
you haven't you haven't had any hard
inquiries where you applied for
something even a cell phone or anything
like that nope nope nothing like that
hmm yeah well the okay what we usually
find when it's taking much longer than
six months is somebody's got something
open on there of some kind that's what
you want to go back and triple check
that and check it with all three of them
all three of the credit bureaus uh and
not just one and not just Credit Karma
okay so get in there and if you're
really concerned about this and you are
enough to call here so you got to do
that but zero activity uh should for six
months and no accounts open there's no
credit history there to score should get
you to an indeterminable or a zero
credit score which I've had for well
over 30 years that's kind of fun that's
a fun stat hey I have a question so if
somebody's in baby step two they paid
off all their debt then they go to baby
step three they stack up the cash for an
emergency fund pretty quickly and then
they want to buy a house they're somehow
able to get the down payment pretty
quickly if their score is kind of going
down in that period of time can they
still get manual under or do they need
to wait till it goes to zero uh well it
won't go to Z well if they had if they
don't currently have a house yeah it
would go to zero yeah you're probably
going to have to I mean you can't it's
gonna be tough to land one if you've got
a 500 or a 600 score it's gonna be hard
uh to do manual underwriting around that
because that score is still sitting
there it's still real
um so yeah you've got to wait to for it
to become indeterminable but typically
it's six but typically it takes six to
nine months get your down payment
together right after baby step two is
completed anyway so you don't own a home
you have zero activity of any kind zero
counts of any kind open no outstanding
anything old or new nothing on there
that's moving because anything that
moves will bump that number
very good point yeah and it's very it's
pretty sensitive we do know that
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Nick
and Brittany are with us hey guys how
are you good how are you welcome welcome
where do you all live Dalton Georgia oh
just down the road welcome to Nashville
how much debt have you paid off we paid
off 123
544.28 months excellent and your range
of income during that two and a half
years Peak was about 190 we're about to
know 130 now
um logo was about 90 000. oh ninety to
one 90 to 190 we're about 130 now so
okay all right 90 to 190 to a third one
goodness gracious what do you all do for
a living
um I'm a speech language pathologist so
when we started I worked in the school
systems and I um switched over and I
know I work in home health oh okay I'm a
nurse Okay cool so both of you could
work all you wanted to lately yes yeah
so this is like a covid thing it
happened right in the middle of covet
huh it did WOW or right around that time
is when you got started what kind of
debt was 124.
um so student loans and a car payment uh
normal huh oh yeah how long y'all been
married uh we just celebrated our fourth
anniversary well congratulations thank
you so a couple years into marriage
you're looking down the barrel of covet
or whether you know it or not and you
look up and you say uh we have too much
debt tell me the story what happened
what got you started on this Ramsay
stuff so I actually bought your book
um several years ago but it was my
husband he read it on our honeymoon
actually laying on the beach in Hawaii
[Laughter]
but it wasn't until March 2020
um he really started we had our first in
December of 2019 and so I think the
financial
worry hit him and so he was like well we
got to get this done and then when they
shut off uh interest for student loans
we were like this is the best time to do
it they're not gaining interest so we
just hit the ground running and um in
March of 2020 this was when the world
shut down it was yeah so this is the
time you choose to attack this yeah
lived at work for the next several
months but um it paid off
um we were kind of Davis I would say
honestly for close to the first year
um my grandmother really just um out of
nowhere asked you know she kind of saw
what we were doing
um she asked about how much I had left
on my student loans we paid off about 20
on mine so far had about 20 left
um we I woke up one day and my balance
was zero so um yeah
20 grand so that really kind of just uh
kick-started us even more yeah just to
really get it more focused and more
intentional and I'll even say I wasn't
really on board with the whole damn
Ramsay thing I'm a spender I love to
travel we live three hours from Disney
so I wanted to go to Disney like every
chance we got so when he came to me and
was like let's do this I was like oh
we're fine like everybody has debt but
then when his grandmother paid off his
debt and I realized we only had my
student loans in the car it became more
realistic so we had a goal to do it in
four years by the time we were 30 and we
did it in 28 months wow yeah that's
outstanding so there's a lot of Spenders
listening right now who are in the same
boat right they're resistant they don't
they don't want to right now they want
to go to Disney they want to travel what
would you tell them to encourage them to
just get started um it's worth it
through the whole thing he kept quoting
um we have to live like no one else so
later we can live like no one else and
that was my I hated that quote I can't
tell you how many times that was spoken
to me because I live 10 minutes from
Target 10 minutes from TJ Maxx and
that's all I wanted to do um you know I
got married I wanted to decorate my home
I had my first baby I wanted to buy all
the things for him but in reality I was
like you know I want to be able to take
them to Disney when they're older um
when it's more meaningful for them and I
don't want to have to worry about the
payments or the car payments
um and so I was like okay if we can do
this um if by the time we're 30 then you
know it'll make it we'll have more time
afterwards to do all the things if we
just buckle down and do it now so I
think it's is it Ken Coleman that says
do what you got to do so then you can do
what you want to do yep yeah that kept
coming out so over and over again so how
does it feel now after all the sacrifice
and all the work how does it feel
amazing we actually went to Disney in
September
that's how we celebrated but we actually
he sold his plasma to pay for the trip
so he still didn't put money aside for
Disney he was like we're not slowing
down we need our emergency funds so
that's how we paid for our district
that's all it was worth it I'll do it
again Wow way to go you guys very cool
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
um I'd say realize you're a team you're
you're both trying to pull in the same
direction
um it's so easy just to get caught up in
the the selfishness every day you know I
want this I want that
um I think this would be best for us
when in reality we got married and we
became one
um and it's just hey we're both pulling
the same direction try to get on the
same page and really just get going and
I think it's important too to have your
why if you're just if you don't know why
you're doing it then you kind of get
lost and you don't pay it off with as
much intensity we you know wanted to be
able to travel now that we have two we
want to be able to travel and see family
that had moved away and we really just
wanted the freedom to go and do and not
have those student loans or the car
payments so we actually got down to
about our last 10 000 this summer and
sold the car that we had just paid off
in May and walked away with money so we
could get out of debt faster yeah just
be done with it yes sir drive a stake in
its heart yeah that's it I like it well
done you guys thank you so much shall we
ever go back in debt absolutely not both
of you not even for Disney
we'll wait a little while who are your
biggest cheerleaders
um I would say our family and then you
know just each other there were days
when I remember you know he was very
addicted to Dave Ramsey
became almost like a curse word in our
house and I just remember looking at him
before I got on board and I was just
like you know
this is too much we talked about
finances every time we got in the car he
wanted to turn the Ramsey Show on um but
then once I got on board
um we really just became a team and you
know because everybody would say well
just take the trip you know you're in
your 20s just take the trip you won't
regret it and like maybe but I may
regret you know the 10 grand that I
added on to my debt now you know we're
28 years old and we can take the trip if
we want to anywhere you want to go
exactly payment in the world well done
you guys very proud of you hey we got a
copy of Total Money Makeover for you to
give away to somebody and get them
started and the baby steps millionaires
our latest number one bestseller which
is uh the definitely the next chapter in
you guys Story You're gonna be there
before you know it on this yes and uh
literally living like no one else
there it is again and uh Financial Peace
University one year membership if you
want to go through it that's fine or
give it to somebody either way it's the
live and give bundle we'll give it to
you at the commercial break here but
congratulations bring the kiddos up and
introduce them what are their names and
ages we have Jackson he's two and then
we have Kaden who is 11 months old all
right way to go big guys I love it well
that's a family tree right there that's
changed by Mom and Dad being grown-ups
and delaying pleasure to win very very
well done you guys Nick and Brittany
from Dalton Georgia 124
000 paid off in 28 months making 90 to
190 to 130. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream ready it's ready three
two one
foreign
[Applause]
this is how it's done
if you were a curse word in their house
for a while now they like you well now
they love you he comes and goes it comes
and goes I'm I'm a mixed blessing that's
what I am but the uh
it's a spiritual gift but uh yeah I
think there's a lot of lessons in that
for listeners in the the you know the
importance of spouses working together
and
um the importance of listening to each
other and the importance of not over
clubbing someone over the head with our
stuff uh because if you do it if he'd
done that just a little bit more this
wouldn't work at all and he went to the
edge on a little too much Dave there a
little too much Ramsay there in that mix
but uh but it worked out and they both
got on board they both got unified and
that's the trick the unity is a big big
deal this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
author is my co-host today it's
Christina deloney and I were talking
about this the other day there's several
pieces of research out there
that uh talk about that that married
people people who are married versus
single or versus uh shacking up
uh have a financial advantage and and
the researchers have always called it
the marriage Advantage
um that that they tend to build more
wealth than any other category
um and
um also tend to move uh uh as a category
not not it's a generalization but I mean
in other words there's exceptions within
each category but they also tend to move
faster in their incomes and their
careers
uh and uh researchers have long tried to
figure out what is causing that exactly
but they call it the marriage advantage
that it's to your advantage
statistically uh as far as wealth goes
income and wealth in general to be
married uh Wall Street Journal comes out
today with yet another study moving in
together doesn't match the financial
benefits of marriage but why a walk down
the aisle can be a route to greater
wealth and prosperity for couples in the
U.S married people have higher net
worths and are more likely to be
homeowners than their unmarried
counterparts their age as of 2019 the
median net worth for cohabitating
checking up couples age 25 to 34 was 17
000 a quarter of that of 68 000 married
couples of exactly the same age range so
25 the net worth of a married couple on
average according to data from the
Federal Reserve Bank of St Louis for
singles is 7 three hundred dollars over
the past two decades Americans are
moving in together at higher rates and
the share of U.S adults who are
currently married steadily declined from
close to 60 percent in the 90s to half
uh to under half in 2019 according to
Pew who did the research over the same
period the share of adults 18 to 44
living with a partner climbed to 59
percent many young couples now approach
marriage as a Capstone event uh the
sociology professor says that John if
you build an ark the Cornerstone
uh while there are legal and tax
advantages to marriage research suggests
the financial security and long-term
mindset of those who tie the knot may
also be a powerful driver of wealth more
married couples pool their money such as
sharing savings accounts and investing
together to achieve certain goals
cohabitating couples are less likely to
combine finances and Investments working
with two incomes and combining their
Investments to maximize compound
interest can significantly increase a
couple's Financial prospects the
research shows simply put married people
may be more likely to be on the same
page financially and housing is one of
the biggest factors in establishing a
couple's wealth compared with single
people and cohabitating Couples married
couples hold a larger concentration of
housing wealth they're more likely to
own a home if you're married than you
are if you're with a roommate
socioeconomic factors play a role in the
difference between married and partner
wealth the higher your income the
likelier it is you'll marry
well that would affect these numbers and
you know that'd be a cause and effect
issue right there you know which one's
causation and which one's correlation at
that point but
yeah but yet this is fresh data and
showing the advantages of marriage and I
think the couple that just did the debt
free scream they're a perfect example of
this data and how it can be effective I
mean in their story they're talking
about how they got on the same page they
set goals they set a why and they really
learn to work together I think a lot of
people who are just cohabitating they're
not having those conversations they're
not getting into you know shared goals
and a shared mindset of really attacking
their finances well what we do know and
this is fairly easy to extrapolate into
this conversation with with reasonable
certainty
um is that
there's a there is a direct correlation
between the length of your planning
window
how far out in the future you look with
money and how much money you have if you
think thank God it's Friday oh God it's
Monday and you live for the weekend
you're Huey Lewis and the News right uh
then you're going to be broke your whole
life YOLO right you know that's where
you're going to be you're not gonna have
any money because you don't plan past
Friday night you're just trying to drink
your face off on the weekend and forget
it and you're not planning but when we
when we interview wealthy people the
wealthier they are the longer their
planning window has been for many years
and that's what caused them to be
wealthy in other words when they get
ready to buy a car they don't think
about
this weekend I don't think about this
year they think about five years from
now how's this car purchase going to
affect me they have and when you think
longer term you automatically will
invest more because you're thinking long
term you're believing there is a future
and I'm I and I'm I know my future self
needs to like my current self but um
future self doesn't talk to
um
a present self with the the broker
somebody is and the more likely they are
to be broke so if you want to go from
broke to wealthy the point is change
your planning window mindset quit living
for the weekend and start thinking okay
in 50 years where do I want to be
I want to change my family tree how
about in 150 years
what do I want my great grandkids to be
let's look at compound interest at 150
years and play with some numbers that
will blow your freaking mind by the way
uh how many hundreds of millions of
dollars that can become you can be old
man Rockefeller old man Vanderbilt uh
old lady Vanderbilt whatever get this
thing started so that planning window
thing comes in there so that comes into
then this discussion of marriage
as if you're married
unless you are planning to divorce right
now you are thinking you're going to do
Life 50 years from now with this person
right yeah and when you're cohabitating
you're thinking well maybe
maybe that's the chance it's not exactly
sure and it changes your it shortens
your planning window when you're shocked
instead of married and so that's one of
the things that I've always thought it
gives you the marriage Advantage because
very few cohabitating couples think
what's gonna what's gonna what's life
gonna be like in 40 years
right well I think it's interesting this
article says that a lot of people see it
as a as a Cornerstone event so what this
means is that people see an economic bar
they need to clear before they get
married couples wait until they have
good jobs a car that won't break down
maybe even a house then they get married
which I think is interesting because
it's like they're trying to do something
in in order to get themselves it'd be a
lot easier right they're married but
they're actually holding themselves back
yeah that's that's interesting that the
data shows that yep so if you're in that
boat and you're feeling you know
hesitant to get married because you feel
like you have to meet a certain
barometer you need to have a certain
amount of your debt paid off you feel
like you need to have a better job or a
house that actually could be working
against you if you actually find the
right partner if you find someone that
you know you want to be with for the
rest of your life getting married
actually could set you on way better
footing financially and it it is not
smart to combine your accounts with
somebody you're not married to totally
and there is uh all kinds of data
including this data here that says
combined accounts I have a tendency
towards more wealth again it's a unified
look at the future it's a fairly simple
concept if you're not thinking about the
future you're not going to have one
right you know if you're not intentional
about future you're not going to have
one and you know I don't care if you're
26 or you're 36 you're shacking up you
aren't that you're not talking about
changing my family tree that doesn't
come up
otherwise you would have already gone
done
if you want to change your family tree
you need to have a family
to change the tree I mean you know
there's not there's not even a tree not
even a family so I mean you're you're
not thinking that way you the inherent
in the socioeconomic and the psychology
of living together versus marriage is
short-term thinking versus long-term
thinking and that will always limit your
wealth so you know these guys that call
us up here and they go well you know
we've been engaged for 10 years and I'm
like dude painter get off the ladder
really and they do call us and tell us
that and I've had and I've had a few
calls over the years that they've been
separated but not divorced for seven
years and I'm like why well I don't want
to I don't want to get divorced well you
are divorced you just hadn't admitted it
yet oh my gosh that is not a good
long-term strategy
where there is no vision that people
perish
if you think long term and you think
long term with your partner called
marriage you have a much higher
statistical probability of Building
Wealth and therefore if you don't do
that on purpose then you have no right
to whine about having not built wealth
it's not anybody's fault but yours
ding ding the marriage Advantage this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsesolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
actual amazing relationships Christina
Ella's number one best-selling author
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
we invite you to join us the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five Jacqueline in Phoenix
is going to start off this hour hey
Jacqueline what's up
hi Dave thanks for taking my call sure
um so I'm curious if I'm on baby step
two or baby step six
um my husband and I have saved for a
house and we had a down payment and
while looking for a mortgage my
grandmother offered to let me borrow
from my trust fund and the expectation
was that I would pay it back because she
doesn't want me to have my trust fund
until after she passes and so I've been
tackling the debt like it's baby step
two and my husband thinks maybe we
should just chill out a little and
chocolate like baby step six
you said you had a down payment for the
house previously is that correct what
was that down payment
40 you had 40 down payment and then you
borrowed from Grandma
yes okay how much did you borrow for her
from her
230 000. was that the rest of the house
yes
okay
so you owe your trust fund for your home
yes
um
it's a bad baby step six
okay
so um how much is in this trust fund
um I don't know exactly if I definitely
at least half a million
still after you took 200 out
yes
okay so the trust fund was left from
who to you
my grandma is leaving it to me is
leaving it so she's already oh she
opened she put the money in there while
she's alive for you her granddaughter
750 thousand dollars
yes and then she agreed to loan the
money from the trust fund to you what
happens if you don't pay it
Legally Legally
oh um I was told that I would just get
the balance of what's in the trust fund
so I wouldn't owe the trust fund any
money I would just get whatever is left
so you did not legally do a lien on the
house or the trust fund that is yours
could actually foreclose on you
you didn't file a mortgage at the
courthouse
no
were there any paperwork signed
uh yeah
there was paperwork signed
yes on the loan
and it's more like just a document
between my grandmother and me and a
lawyer
I I'm sorry say that again
it's just a document between me and my
grandmother and the document states that
you're to repay this at a certain rate
yeah it's just paying a certain dollar
amount every month until it's paid back
or until she passes is there interest on
that
no that's an interest-free loan
okay
um
I'm curious what what is Grandma's
reasoning for not giving you the money
versus lending it does she have yeah
which is what she should have done
um she just doesn't want me to have
access to it until after she passes for
some reason but she gave you access to
it
yes she did she's talking out of both
sides of her mouth
I guess she doesn't want my cousins and
siblings to also have access to theirs
oh she didn't want to set a precedent
yes
that the others go well you did that for
Jaclyn oh yeah now that makes a little
more sense I was getting ready to get
after Grandma here for a second
um
well it's maybe step six for sure to
answer your original question it's not
two it's a home mortgage it's just a
weird Home Mortgage agreed
yes okay so there's no question about
what this is for what the money went to
why you have two hundred thousand
dollars in debt it's all about this
house and if you were to sell the house
you would pay off the mortgage if you
were to refinance the house you'd pay
off the mortgage which would be repaying
the trust fund that someday will be
yours anyway
okay I'm gonna get tacky are you okay
with that
how old's your grandmother I was going
to ask the same thing uh like early 70s
72 73 Maybe our early 70s
yeah okay how's your health
she's great okay so this is going to go
a while
actually I mean we've been tackling it
like it's baby step two so I only have
three more years left on it but I was
just wondering like if I were to go back
to the agreed upon amount I could I mean
it would take it like four years but I
was just wondering I would do I would do
the agreed on Pawn them out for four
years
yeah because baby step two is is gazelle
intensity baby step six is you move from
intensity to intentionality and
um what I would tell you there is put 15
of your income away to retirement
um and baby step four save money for
your kids college and baby step five in
any money you can get out of your budget
beyond that is extra payments on the
mortgage that's a normal baby steps
answer and I'm gonna apply it in this
baby steps answer and I'm going to apply
it in this weird situation
okay yeah we just we've never had that
because we grew up on the ramsing plan
like our parents gave us your books as
we were kids so we've never had that so
we just we freaked out when we suddenly
had that yeah how old are you guys
uh 33 and 34. okay
yeah so are you putting 15 away in
retirement
yes
okay so you were already treating it
like and then above that you're paying
more than your normal agreed payment
yeah and then we both have second jobs
okay I might back off on the intensity
of a reasonable life and pay the regular
payment and what you can above that with
having a reasonable life an intentional
life and then get rid of this
wow
there's only one thing keeping me from
saying grandma made a mistake here and
that's the precedent with the other
cousins yeah maybe she's got a crazy
because it does have well Nami she
doesn't have a point there
um
but um see the difference in me though
is this we told our kids Fair
is where cotton candy and the Tilt aware
were alive
fair is is my money I decide what I want
to do with it that's fair and so if I
want to give your brother more I'll give
him a brother more it's my money
um and so if your cousin called up and
said if I was your grandmother I would
do away with this alone because I think
it's weird it's icky it's strange the
borrower's slave to the lender I got a
weird feeling in my stomach talking to
you about it I don't like it so I would
pay it off and reduce your amount and if
the cousins come around and go no
I just stood there for her I'm not doing
it for you by the way it's free money so
you don't get a vote my money you know
you can just say No No's a complete
sentence and fear fair is where there's
cotton candy in the tiltor room it's not
fair well my money you know go visit the
fair not socialism it's capitalism this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
stagnation recession stock market's
failing falling we're out of we're gonna
die okay all right everybody calm down
uh if you're investing this is not the
time to panic you got to stay
level-headed
listen no one gets hurt on a roller
coaster ride except those that jump off
in the middle so history shows us that
the economy recovers time and time again
happened even after the Great Depression
even after 9 11 and even after 08
actually a great time to invest when you
consider that it's coming back up you're
catching it while it's down it's on sale
and who doesn't love a good deal but you
got to be smart about investing you
gotta have someone who can guide you
through all of this and if you need help
finding an investing Pro check out our
smartvester program it's an easy way to
find Pros who truly serve with
Excellence they'll be here to be there
to help you figure out what's best for
you and stay focused on your long-term
goals to get connected with up to five
smart investor Pros in your area so you
can pick the one you want go to
ramseysolutions.com smartvestor and you
can talk with the pros pick the one you
want to work with and make an easy
investing plan that you feel confident
about because with the heart of a
teacher they'll sit down and lead you
the same way we would it's what we do
here Emily's with us in Youngstown Ohio
hi Emily how are you
uh good how are you good to talk to you
you too how can we help
okay so my short question is I am a
stay-at-home mom and looking for advice
as to whether or not I should look for
some sort of income or go back to work
full-time or part-time or stay at home
with the kids uh we have been following
your baby steps for like four years
um we kind of have been working to this
point with two little kids we
um uh we paid off all of our debt we
saved up for a 20 down payment on house
and I think we weren't as prepared for
me to cut my salary as we thought we
were and we're struggling kind of to to
make the budget every month now that
we've moved to one salary and
um
yeah just you know we've been having a
lot of conversations like should my
husband look for an increase in his line
of work should I look for something
part-time how much is your house payment
uh our house payment is 966 what's your
husband's take-home pay a month pay uh a
month is 2900.
so your house payment's one-third of
your take-home pay
and how many kids you got
okay okay how old are they
uh three and eight months okay
and so he makes forty eight thousand a
year
well okay maybe I should have special
that so it's it's a variable pay so
there are like months
how much is annual income uh 67.
okay that's not
2900
to some months he gets um
part of it
okay so part of it is the scene and part
of it is a little bit of like a
commission sort of oh I see for some
months so the 2900 is the salary only
yes that's correct so that's not your
real income your real income is 67 000
minus taxes
what does he do you
um he is a sales force technician so he
works with it kind of stuff okay okay
and when did you all make the transition
from two incomes to one
uh four months ago I'm a teacher so at
the end of last or I was a teacher so at
the end of last school year was I sent
in my resignation okay so did y'all buy
the house before you left your job
yes we did okay
I'm kind of wondering so have you all
done the math on about how much more you
would need per month to comfortably
cover your bills
okay yeah I mean I think between the
kids would be about
500 is kind of what we were thinking
five to seven hundred to be really
comfortable I I think you're uh debt
free and you have a 900 house payment
with sixty seven thousand dollars
income I think you've had some other
lifestyle things that you need to take
out but this is a doable budget without
you working if you want it to be if you
want to work to pass some luxury items
or to eat out more often then you can
that's up to you but do you have to to
survive not with the numbers you gave me
you have no payments but a house payment
your payment house payment's 900 and you
make a 67 000 income I don't think
you're budgeting well I think your
budgets are loose and you've not written
them down in in detail and the two of
you pinky swearing spit Shake by God
we're sticking to what's on this paper I
don't think you're doing that
well and I do wonder if there's
something
I do wonder if there's also like a
middle ground where you mentioned you
know do you take a job out of the house
and I'm assuming maybe you're thinking
you know an official part-time job or an
official full-time job but with five to
seven hundred dollars is the gap and as
a former teacher you could make quite a
bit tutoring and really work around your
kids schedule and and just have a lot of
flexibility so it's like if you don't
want to buckle down on that budget quite
as tight or you want to eat out or you
want to get you know extra clothes or
something like that and that's just a
lifestyle choice you want to make let's
let's clarify emotionally though what
we're doing here okay you can live and
invest for retirement on 67 with a 900
house payment you can do it if you
tighten your budget and you watch what
you're doing and the two of you write it
down and the two of you stick to it you
can do that now if you want to do some
things above that and you're willing to
work for those things that's fine but
you're not allowed to say oh I had to go
pick up a part-time job because we just
couldn't make it on my husband's income
no that's not true you can't say that
because you can make it on your
husband's income if that's what you want
to do but if you want to do some I I'm
fine with you doing some tutoring but
but but we can't say it's because we
couldn't make it you can make it true
well she even admitted that she she's
been a little loosey-goosey on the
budget no question I can do that budget
in my head it's there so hey folks if
you like this show help us out three
ways one if you're listening on
podcaster YouTube subscribe
uh leave a review a five-star review we
don't need any one star reviews thank
you they're not helpful
if you can't I mean mama you say if you
can't say something nice don't say
nothing at all amen good rule for you
people on the internet and uh all of you
radio or podcast or YouTube
tell somebody about it share it with a
friend if you have the ability to share
a link share a link
a link to your local
talk radio station that carries our show
thank you for that but spread the word
for us uh whatever so subscribe review
and
um share this is the rule and that's how
you can help us if we've helped you see
we don't charge you for this it's free
so that's that's your that's your bill
right I just sent you a bill you got to
help us out well a lot of you have
friends that are drowning like money has
been taboo for so long and a lot of
people are afraid to talk about it but a
lot of people in your circle are staying
up at night stressed out about finances
and you can be that person who brings
them hope and brings them life change
yeah you don't have to tell them it's
about money you just tell them it's
funny
you can lie
well you know the weird thing was when
we very first started on the air
um 30 years ago
um I mean it we were so country fried it
was awful it was like you're listening
to the money game you know I mean it was
it was it was bad it sounds like we're
broadcasting from a double wide
um and you know what but the information
was remarkably the same and
um people started spreading the word and
that's how we're here 30 years later uh
people telling people they're telling
the French you have to listen to the
show you got to check this out you got
to check this out you can't argue with
life change even if it comes from a
redneck yep there you go
so what'd you just call me
so the uh uh yeah I know it's just it is
what it is but the uh yeah there's a
thing going around YouTube did you see
that thing that me on a Christian TV
show like when I was 30 I saw that and
and the comments are all like God he's
so country and he's so kind and gentle I
was I I've kind of lost my um
I just don't suffer fools like I used to
but
um
yeah and but another thing is they say
he says the exact same thing that's true
I do say the exact same thing I did when
I was 30. no question about it this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
with health care costs Rising learn how
Christian Healthcare Ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
foreign
[Music]
number one best-selling author and
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
thank you for joining us America in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage Nick and Susan are with us
hey guys how are you great how are you
good how are you good good better than
we deserve where do y'all live Milford
New Hampshire oh wow nice haul down to
Nashville yes sir very cool and here to
do a debt free scream how much did you
pay off fifty seven thousand good for
you and your how long did this take 44
months cool and your range of income
during that time uh about 74 to 80 with
side hustles
cool what kind of side hustles did you
do
um a lot of overtime we worked holidays
uh I sold at consignment stores uh
doordash yeah good what do you all do
for a living I'm in L A and I'm a
physical therapy assistant oh wow okay
cool well kind of debt was the 57 uh so
it was a student loans a car a bunch of
credit cards and a phone you were like
normal people yes sir how long you been
married four years okay cool and so
right after marriage 44 months ago uh
you look down and go ah this is a mess
we're going to clean it up tell me the
story how'd you get about this and start
doing the Ramsey stuff I actually told
her I was going to do this part uh so
when I first graduated college uh the
gentleman I was working for handed me
her book and he goes hey you're going to
want to read this it'll help you and
that's all he said to me I was like oh
cool thank you very much
yeah like he didn't really uh not to
speak ill of him but he didn't like give
me a story of it so I was like oh okay
and then I preached through but I didn't
get a lot of it and like a lot of young
men money wasn't really a thing like oh
you're supposed to be in debt like
that's just how it's supposed to work
right uh so I'm like yes I had credit
card debt and I had all the other stuff
and then my go-to strategy which never
worked by the way is like oh when I get
my tax return I'll just pay out that'll
be that'll that'll be what saves me yeah
exactly and every year I'm like huh that
didn't work that's weird uh but then I
got older and then I also met my future
wife and then we got married and she
took your course without me she's like
hey I want to do this with my friend you
mind if I go I'm like absolutely please
have fun and then she comes back she's
like hey you should do the course of me
I'm like oh yeah okay so I like my old
balls yeah exactly but
um having some wiser man around me
they're like hey if your wife shows
interest in something you probably
should too so after she said that to me
I took it thought about it for like a
day and I'm like yeah okay let's do this
let's let's do the course I'm gonna
learn something regardless
uh and then when I took the course A lot
of it just made a lot of sense and we
had just shortly had our daughter
and going from a young man to having no
responsibility other than yourself like
uh I kind of did think backwards I was
giving without actually being
financially stable I'm like oh you need
money for gas here you go oh you need
food here you go I live in ramen noodles
for a month what do I care uh I have
children an entirely different world
my wife was already good with money
before I even came into the picture all
this was heard of getting me on the same
track uh so after we took the course and
it all made sense she's like hey let's
let's do this and I said okay
um of course at what point in this whole
thing did you remember that this was the
same guy in the book that you threw away
uh actually I didn't realize it until we
got to the course and they handed me
your book oh you're like oh I used to
have one of those okay actually I told
her I'm like hey I've got this in
storage someplace she's like why didn't
you read it I'm like that's a great
question this is a fair question yeah I
don't I don't have a good answer for you
but we were running through the course
uh one of the things she said to me was
like Hey if when we do this it was never
if it was when I want to go down and I
want to do the scream I'm like oh yeah
sure like they're going to pick us like
I agreed
but being a man of my words we finished
we paid off debt and she's like hey I'm
going to email them and see if we can do
the screen I'm like yeah okay great I
think it was a day later I got the uh
the full caps text we got picked
going to Nashville I love it well way to
go guys very cool yeah good on you for
listening to the wife and good on you
for leading the charge that is awesome
um so okay you said you did a lot of
side hustles what did this journey look
like for y'all uh working a lot yeah oh
yeah I mean the other thing too is right
when we decided to do this just before
we started I literally had a car blow up
so we had to get another car so that got
added into the uh the debt snowball you
get covered right in the middle of your
deal well that's just it too so she was
working a full-time job covet hits and
now she has to be a stay-at-home mom
stay-at-home teacher yeah so I'm working
every holiday I can
um every weekend she's doing double
shifts while I stay home with the kids
um just everything we can do to pay off
debt but you guys are incredible I'm so
proud of you thank you well done well
done how's it feel amazing oh yeah it
feels really good and the best part is
all the people that we talked to about
it and they're like oh yeah but that
actually you can't really do that or
that doesn't really work it's like it
did but we we did yeah but there's us
yeah yeah like we're actually the proof
that's it so what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is if
somebody will actually listen trust the
process like it's the these steps aren't
complicated it's simple but following
through with it is where the dedication
comes in
44 months by God that's a long trick and
throw a little covet in the middle of it
yeah just for fun
actually helped us with all the bonuses
that our work yeah because we're both in
healthcare so they just wanted yeah zoom
zoom yeah oh yeah so like I wanted you
around for sure yeah yeah and people
were quitting left and right in our jobs
because of the health scare so they're
like hey we need people we'll pay you x
amount extra if you want to come in yeah
awesome we'll be there you're like I'll
do this yeah so what's next what's next
now that your your debt free past baby
step two saving for a house all right
good for you that's exciting I'm gonna
love it and you brought the kiddos bring
them up tell us their names and ages so
this is Arya who's four just turned five
oh just turned five excuse me typical
dad oh this is Natalie 11. all right
very good good stuff well we've got a
copy of Total Money Makeover for you to
give away to someone with a better
explanation than you got and uh baby
steps millionaires the latest number one
bestseller because that's the next
chapter in your story we want to hear
from you when you become baby steps
millionaires you're on your way and a
one-year membership to Financial Peace
University and again you've been through
the class so you'll be able to give that
to somebody and probably got somebody in
mind that maybe you can get them going
that'd be great that's what this is all
about the live and give bundle there for
you congratulations you guys we're proud
of you very well done Nick and Susan
Natalie and Aria Milford New Hampshire
57
000 paid off in 44 months making 74 to
80 counted down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one
[Applause]
I love it
there is a really good life lesson that
is evolving on the debt-free stage in
the last few months here's the life
lesson
you remember when you thought that
everything as you knew it any chance of
prospering any chance of winning that
covet had stolen at all
you remember how coveted was the worst
possible thing the quarantine the loss
of a job and and we were all freaked out
some of you were so freaked out that
you're still trying to emotionally
recover from your freak out here's an
interesting number for you
since the quarantine
82
of our debt free screams since the
middle of 2020.
82 of our debt-free screams have been
that they claim they got out of debt
because of covet meaning covered
indirectly was a blessing
it caused them to focus
the wife got on board with the baby
steps took an extra job that was covered
related uh what got us started the
pandemic scared us to death when covet
hit we changed careers the pandemic
changed my outlook on spending my change
in spending habits during covet I was
able to work more and got a lot of
income during covet covert it was
actually good increased his salary
pandemic made their dream more
attainable side hustles exploded things
opened after covid when covet hit my
business went crazy these are actual
phrases from some of the 82 people that
have had that said covid is to blame
for their getting out of debt
isn't that interesting
that's powerful yeah it's like you know
covid was like a fire and a lot of
people ran away from the fire these
people actually ran towards it and put
out the fire or yeah and got paid well
change their family tree in the process
I mean listen it was a valid thing to be
afraid but isn't it interesting that
when you look back on the things that
you were afraid of how many times they
turned into a blessing that's the life
lesson
and these people here man I mean they
were able to work like crazy their
income went way up during because of
covet and um
it's just a it's a thing to remember
when I when I think I'm going to die
from this I'm probably just being a
drama queen
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
Christine Ellis Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today our question of the day
comes from blinds.com they have a 100
percent satisfaction guarantee that
means even if you mismeasure you pick
the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free free samples free
shipping and new promos all the time if
you want a great deal use the promo code
Ramsey at blinds.com today's question
comes from Brian in Nebraska my wife and
I live in Nebraska she's graduating from
dental school and we are expecting our
first child in may as well the only debt
we will have is a combined three hundred
thousand dollars in student loan debt
once she is done with school and a
mortgage of 180 000 with 40 to 60 000 in
equity I currently make sixty two
thousand a year as an architect she has
a job offer in Memphis Tennessee to
teach as a professor for 160 000 or work
in Nebraska for 100 to 125 000 a year we
do we move to Memphis Tennessee with a
newborn where she can make more money
and we can sell the house to put our
Equity to pay our student loans or stay
in Nebraska to continue paying down debt
and have a community that is able to
help with the baby
well the first thing that struck me is
only three hundred thousand dollars
we only have three hundred thousand it's
not five hundred thousand it's only
three hundred oh my God
yeah the other thing that's interesting
to me is she's graduating from dental
school which that seems to be where the
debt's coming from but then she's going
to be a professor well there's a dental
college in Memphis okay I'll be Teaching
Ministry but do you think it's better to
to start out being a dentist and get
real world experience before teaching
yeah it's obviously not necessary I mean
there's even professors did you have
that had Real World Experience doing
anything except being a professor I mean
that seems like the best route I also
just wonder too like if she became an
actual dentist could she make more money
and knock that debt out quicker he's
saying she's got a hundred and twenty
five thousand dollars really first year
out 100 a quarter on dentist is about
right
I'm a little shocked at how high the
professor's score is that's a pretty
score 106 now and the question is too
okay so if you move down there and you
don't make at least 62 this is not an
upgrade
um
yep he's got to get a job making 62 or
more as an architect in Memphis well
that that'll
go for an architect right it does yeah
yeah there's a lot of questions on this
yeah so
all right let's just let's throw some
assumptions on there so we can answer it
let's say
that you moved to Memphis and you made
80 as an architect and she made a
hundred and sixty okay and you live
there three or four or five years and
you clean up your dad gum mess that
you've made only 300 000 in debt right
um did he say how much Equity 40 to 60
in equity yeah not much okay so that's
not going to move the needle the big
thing that moves the needle is the
income difference
um
foreign
or
we change jobs as an architect in
Nebraska and make more money and she
gets a better job than she's been
offered so far as a dentist and makes
150 in Nebraska if she can make 150 and
he'd make 80 and you hate the idea of
Memphis
instead of Nebraska then I would stay
and it takes you another
what six months to a year to get out of
debt you know if you do that but I you
you seem to be underpaid
right right for your I mean if you have
a four-year degree in architecture and
you're making 62. I got a problem okay
period let's just say that number two
125 is a little low but not super bad
for a first time out out of the gate
dentist that's not bad at all
um
I I kind of think I'm hearing Down Under
that last sentence
uh have Community that's able to help
with a baby do I move away from
everything that I know my family my
roots my church
well another factor to consider is the
fact that like I don't know what that
Community is going to do like how much
they're going to help but but there's
daycare costs as well if you move to
Memphis maybe maybe in Nebraska you have
a grandma who's planning on taking care
of the baby and in Memphis you're going
to have to pay for full-time daycare so
even in that equation just making sure
to factor you got to run that in there
too so
um
if you maximized
your income in both locations it sounds
like Memphis gets you out of debt a year
sooner no one says you have to live
there the rest of your life it's not
required
uh you could go work there three or four
years and then move
back to Nebraska that would be fine if
you hate it
um you could look at it as an adventure
you know it's not a uh it's not a
permanent decision forever and ever I
mean you could look at it as an
adventure and go do that like for
instance these people that are
contractors with the military and they
go to Dubai for a year and make 6X what
they would have made in the states and
pay off everything and they can
basically give up a year and they have a
little adventure and Dubai and go do it
and you know or whatever and there's a
in the sandbox one way or another and
there's people doing that and uh that's
that huge but it's a matter of looking
at it I think that I'm going to be away
from community and everything that I
know
has a rest of your life feel to it that
isn't required
as far as I know you can still
um
they still allow you to leave Memphis
once you move there
true
I mean but I'm also thinking like
personally she is graduating from dental
school so there's going to be a huge
life change just in going from being a
full-time student to working and then
she just had a baby she's got a newborn
so even just man the first year
postpartum I would not have been super
excited about an adventure across
country and moving away from family so
there's also just the emotional aspect
of like what does she really want like
what what is her capacity you know we're
going to Minneapolis tomorrow night okay
and um I've got friends from that grew
up in Minneapolis they were born and
bred there everything they knew was
there and
um at 50 something years old they said
I'm tired of being cold I'm leaving
and they moved to Nashville
and they lived down the street from us
you know and they're they're sweet
people they go back to Minneapolis
occasionally see their friends but they
were tired of it and you may be tired on
Nebraska I don't know but it doesn't say
that here true what seems to be between
the lines here is you would hate leaving
Nebraska and the only reason you'll be
doing it would be for a little extra
money and I would challenge you instead
to go maximize your incomes where you
are and stay 100 yeah and if it takes
you one year longer to get out of debt
by doing that but don't stay there and
make 62 and 100 which is more than which
is all she could have made that much by
herself
because you two both minimized the crap
if you make 60 and she makes 100 that's
162 she got an opportunity to make 160
by herself in Memphis that's not okay so
if you're going to stay in Nebraska you
need to go up your game yes somewhat it
doesn't have to be as high uh as the
Memphis and the Memphis steel does not
work at all dude if you don't get an
architectural job they're making more
than you make now right well and I'd
also be curious about cost of living
like it seems like I mean I'm not super
familiar with Nebraska but it seems like
it'd be cheaper to live there versus in
Memphis but probably but Memphis is not
that high but also just make sure to
compare that because even the equity you
have in your house 40 to 60 000 it's not
that much money and so just make sure
you compare the the just the cost of
living the cost of daycare all of that
and Factor all that into consideration
because so here's a mistake that people
make in their logic on this and this is
the the subject in general do I move for
a job
it it's as if they're doing is if are am
I doing something wrong if I don't take
a job in a place I hate because it pays
more
no you're not
careers are personal things
personal finance is first personal and
then it's finance and and so you know if
you I'll give you an example okay people
told us with the with the Dave Ramsey
Show in the old days that it will never
be a big radio show if we don't move to
LA or New York and I'm like I've like
visiting LA or New York for about
48 hours and then I'm ready to leave the
chances of me living there is precisely
zero
and if that means that the Dave Ramsey
show is never a big deal because I
refuse to locate in one of those two
cities
um then it won't be no it turns out that
we're the second largest Talk Radio in
America today so those people that said
that didn't know what they were talking
about thank goodness but I made the
choice quality of life on Nashville
versus those two places oh Dad Gum no
question I'm chuckling a little bit
inside trying to picture you living in
L.A or New York bringing redneck radio
to the big city
well we are broadcasting both of them
thank you very much but yeah
matter of fact highly rated in both of
them so it's working you still won here
we go
golly you and your redneck jokes today
I'm just
come up with some Venezuelan jokes or
something here bring it yeah bring it
bring it this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS of moving and storage
Studios it's the Ramsay show where that
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
Home Mortgage has taken the place of the
BMW as the status symbol of choice we
help people build wealth do work they
love create actual amazing relationships
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Ricky is in Rhode Island hi Ricky
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave thanks for uh thanks for taking
my call I really appreciate it sure
what's up
um so I was just kind of you know
driving around and I was thinking about
like different things financially and I
was thinking uh about how my I I got a
whole life insurance policy that was
purchased by my parents back in 2001 I'm
sorry
and so
um it has like an accumulated value or
cash surrender value of ten thousand uh
811 so I was wondering if it would be
financially smart to
try to withdraw that and put that in
like a money market fund so that it
maybe it grows a little larger a little
faster
how old are you and so just I just want
to get your opinion oh I'm 36. okay you
have married have children
uh single dad two kids okay
you have other life insurance
uh I do through my employer I have uh
term life insurance to my my employer
how much so I think it's 75 000 I
believe what do you make
uh before taxes
uh 62 000 they had me projected making
this year after taxes and insurances
union dues all that comes out I'm a
firefighter how old are your babies
uh my daughter is 10 and my son is uh
nine okay and how much debt do you have
I have ten thousand dollars in uh
vehicle debt uh 228 thousand dollars for
a mortgage and
um that's that's pretty much it okay
all right
um are you ill are you uninsurable can
you get insurance
okay
okay all right so our recommendation and
then I'll tell you why we recommend that
as well is that um someone have uh 10
times to 12 times their income on them
in term life insurance
you may or may not want that much but
let's just say as an example you went
and got a half a million dollars at 36
years old it costs nothing it's very
inexpensive 15 to 20 year level term
insurance it's the cost of a pizza okay
now if you died that money could go into
a trust in mutual funds and would
produce fifty thousand dollars a year
four thousand dollars a month
for your children
okay
okay and that's really the only people
that are dependent upon you that would
suffer if due to your death in terms of
income being your income being gone you
follow me
right okay and so the purpose of life
insurance is to do that now whole life
life insurance sucks
that's why I said I'm sorry when you
said you had one because it's it's uh
it's 20 times more expensive
in other words
what you can buy for five dollars of
term it costs you a hundred in whole
life
and that extra 95 dollars per hundred is
going to build up a cash value inside
which yours has grown to ten thousand
dollars after all of these years
and
if you die they pay only the face value
you do not get your heirs your
beneficiaries do not get the money that
you paid the extra 95 dollars to get
so your face value of your whole life
policy is what thirty thousand forty
thousand
um I'm looking at the the face value
yeah I'm looking at that I don't I'm
looking at the policy now I don't see
where it says the face value or just the
value no that I mean the accumulated
value right now is ten thousand dollars
they accumulate values of cash value and
then my death benefits 100 000. okay
your death benefit okay that's all right
so you you have paid or your parents
have paid five dollars per hundred
dollars
for the 100 000 policy they paid ninety
five dollars into a savings account to
create a ten thousand dollar savings
account called cash value when you die
your your death benefit is one hundred
thousand it's like a savings account
that when you die the bank keeps your
money
which makes it stupid okay it's a
horrible product it is the payday lender
of the middle class all right and if you
leave it in there it's only paying about
one percent uh growth and and until you
die and then they keep it so it's just
ridiculous so what would I do if I woke
up in your shoes I'd get five hundred
thousand dollars worth of term
and I would cash this crap in and I'd
use the ten thousand dollars Christina
that that usually ten thousand dollars
pay off the car I mean yes 100 I know my
eyes kind of lit up whenever I saw you
at ten thousand dollars in a car payment
and I was like oh a lovely coincidence
that's that's pretty perfect
um but I do think it's kind of crazy too
thinking that this was bought in 2001
and a lot of times these life insurance
agents sell this as such a great
investment and this has been around for
21 years and it has just over ten
thousand dollar value like
think about that that that's kind of
crazy if you live to 2 000 you'll be
able to retire on that you know uh two
thousand years old
um not two thousand yeah I mean you're
21 years in and we have proven
mathematically just by the discussion of
the numbers that it sucks and so not to
mention the concept sucks so yeah get
500 000 worth of term insurance go to
xanderinsurance.com shop around get you
the best quote on that
put the beneficiary as a trust for your
kids if you were to die while they're
still minors you probably don't want to
leave it to the X and hope she does a
good job with it no I think that's a bad
plan so just leave it to the kids and uh
the income off of which can be used for
their good in replacement of Child
Support or whatever we want to call it
and then
um you know when they're grown and if
you're still single at that point and
you have no uh no one counting on you at
all and you want to drop the policy
that's okay like you don't really need
car insurance if you don't have a car
right well and hopefully too following
this plan you'll your assets and your
savings will continue to grow so that if
you do end up having a significant other
and you want to leave them something you
will have real money saved in your bank
account yeah I think that's a good point
for the rest of you listening the
typical scenario is let's say you're
like a 32 year old couple and you've got
um two little kids like how old are you
I admit that on air well of course you
are you can't ask you yes you trust me
how you'd make fun of me being 62 every
day so oh my God but okay you're a young
couple thank you with two little kids
I'm gonna pretend you're 32. geez
it doesn't matter the uh the point being
that if something happened to either one
you or your husband today those kids got
to eat from Little from three four years
old all the way to 18 or 20. so you need
life insurance more at that time because
you don't have a unless you got a
million dollars in the bank a million
dollars in mutual funds you need life
insurance more at that time than you do
at any other time
I'm over 30. I'll give you that
whoa well I just had my 32nd anniversary
of my 30th birthday so there you go this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Christina Ellis number one best-selling
author and Ramsay personality is my
co-host today
oh joining us now and for this segment
one of my favorite people on the planet
Lisa turkhurst the president of proverbs
31 multiple best-selling books number
one number one number one number one and
the new book good boundaries and good
buys and that's like goodbye like
bye-bye yeah you're out of here loving
others without losing the best of who
you are Lisa how are you my friend
I am so well thank you so much for that
very generous introduction Dave well we
appreciate you all you do and your
friendship all these years I uh you've
done an incredible job with your writing
career and your ministry and uh we're
just honored to have you congrats on the
new book so you uh you got into our
friend Dr Henry Cloud's territory here
with boundaries did you have fun dancing
in that sandbox
I tried to dance in a little different
box trying to give people
um the spiritual and biblical confidence
to know that boundaries are not just a
good idea they're God's idea but also
I'm speaking from the vantage point of
someone who really struggles with
boundaries and who has struggled with
people pleasing and so I think people
will appreciate
my vulnerability and my full admission
that I'm writing for my struggle not my
strength but I've made really good
strides and I think I can help others do
that same thing
when you do decide to set a boundary and
I was reading one of the pages about
someone coming into your home and you
realize there was a mistake and you had
asked them to leave when you do decide
to set a boundary
um
that number one I don't care who you are
if you're a loud mouth like me or a
sweet person like you either one it
doesn't matter there's still this idea
that this this may not go well
this may result in rejection because
generally someone that you have to set a
boundary with is not someone who likes
boundaries and so they're they're
probably not it's probably not going to
go well so it's scary to do it isn't it
it is scary you know I I love what my
counselor Jim Kress who weighs in
throughout the book says healthy people
respect healthy boundaries unhealthy
people have never met a boundary they
like so it can be scary but here's the
thing if you draw a healthy boundary and
someone rejects you or expresses great
disappointment in you then that person
is eventually going to reject you or
Express great disappointment in you so
you you do have to make peace with that
but also you can say what needs to be
said in a kind way I would say the most
important thing to remember is that we
really shouldn't be putting boundaries
on other people we should draw
boundaries around ourselves to keep
ourselves the same stable and
self-controlled and I think that is
going to be a really helpful Paradigm
Shift when you try to put a boundary on
another person you're in essence trying
to control them and if they're unwilling
or incapable of making the changes you
want you're going to be incredibly
frustrated and feel like a boundary
failure but when you draw a boundary
around yourself then you're able to stay
empowered to do something about the
situation you may find yourself in
that's so good Lisa man so a lot of
relationships they have ups and downs
how does someone know if a relationship
is healthy or unhealthy
well I think there's several factors
that you have to consider and throughout
the book I give checklists to help
people become more self-aware but let me
give you a couple of things to consider
if you find yourself needing to diminish
the best of who you are to cover up the
worst of who someone else is that's an
unhealthy situation if you find yourself
having to normalize or possibly even
just normalizing behaviors that
shouldn't be normalized in Dancing with
dysfunction and other people are
pointing it out but you're wanting to
make excuses for it that's a huge
situation and also if you find yourself
in a situation where you're saying
phrases like I just can't take it
anymore that's a big indication you see
wherever there's chaos there's usually a
lack of a boundary
Lisa turkhurst is our guest this segment
the book brand new book her newest
number one bestseller I'm sure good
boundaries and good buys uh you and I
both uh uh work in the Christian sector
of the world an awful lot Lisa and um
I'm always amazed of the um
the toxic or the dysfunction or the
codependency that someone rolls up under
being Christian
you know like this mislabeling of what
Christian is like a Christian means
doormat or something it doesn't
it doesn't you know I think there are
Bible verses that sometimes are
misunderstood and weaponized to make
people feel guilty or even to make
people drop their boundaries you know
and I think one of those is well didn't
Jesus lay down his life for his friends
yes Jesus did and he modeled that for us
and he commanded us to do the same but
Jesus laid down his life to accomplish a
high and holy purpose he did not lay
down his life to enable bad behavior to
continue
yeah the one I get around here a lot is
um honor your father and mother yeah
Dave but you know Mom is broke and she's
always spent everything she makes and
um and and now she wants eight thousand
dollars a month and um you know and I'm
like well okay if your mom is doing
cocaine we can honor the position of
motherhood that's biblical but we can't
honor the cocaine use that's you know
it's not it's ridiculous but in the name
of Christian we're just supposed to like
turn the other way and and have
absolutely no common sense and that is
not any more biblical than fly of the
moon so fun stuff I love your new book I
love this talk about when
um
When It's Time to Say Goodbye
well good
well good people around you but look
when you are giving access to someone to
your capacity and they are demonstrating
zero responsibility you're not going to
be able to control them and make them
more responsible so your choice is to
draw a boundary around yourself and
reduce the access that you've granted
them for example in finances you know
Dave today you probably won't give out
your security passcode to your bank
account wisely so right is because you
know you have limited resources in your
bank account and you're wise in being
responsible but if you did give that out
then you run the risk of some people not
being responsible so you only give
access to people according to their
demonstrative level of responsibility
hmm and when you know when you've got
someone that's just straight up abusive
you don't have a choice
but to set you know to set it until you
can stop this
you know we're gonna have to have some
distance
so if you've been like if you've been in
a relationship with somebody who's been
treating you unhealthy you know how do
you measure change once you've set those
boundaries you know how do you tell that
they're changing and how long should it
take
well you know trust is built time plus
believable Behavior so it is going to
take time and you need to be able to see
believable Behavior because remember you
the boundaries that you put in place are
to keep you sane safe stable and
self-controlled and so when you have
enough emotional fortitude to maybe test
the waters and and they have
demonstrated over time believable
Behavior then yes of course the
boundaries can be flexible but you know
a big indication is their behavior you
see it we don't want to accuse people of
being a certain way just because they
make a mistake that's what Grace is for
but if you were seeing patterns of
behavior that are unhealthy that they
are unwilling or incapable of changing
then the boundaries must stay in place
yeah that's so good Lisa turkhurst very
wise very strong lady good friend of
ours for many years now gosh I was
trying to count up before we came on
there it's over a decade now isn't it
Lisa
I think so Dave yeah seems like 20
minutes ago you and I were speaking over
at Perry Noble's church and that's
probably been over 10 years ago yeah I
know but now your aging is so let's not
do that
oh no here we go again oh Lisa Turkish
the new book is good boundaries and
goodbyes you always want to read
everything she writes and this one is
absolutely essential there's a lot of
heart on these Pages I've already seen
it you don't want to miss it good stuff
thank you my friend glad to have you
with us
thank you always enjoy Dave this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
's number one best-selling author Ramsay
personality is my co-host today Noah and
Lauren are on the debt free stage hey
guys how are you well Dave how are you
better than I deserve where do you all
live Charleston South Carolina very cool
great town all right how much debt did
you pay off
645 thousand dollars
how long did this take three and a half
years all right and your range of income
during this time it well there was a
range a hundred thousand to about 300
000. wow what do you all do for a living
I'm a real estate agent and teach group
fitness classes part-time on the side
and I'm an airline pilot and a military
pilot as well in the Air Force Reserves
wow so you guys were going hard yeah a
lot of stuff going on busy family went
crazy what kind of debt was the 645. it
was all of our as house you paid off
your house looking at weird people I
love it love it you guys how old are you
I'm 36 I'm 40. all right with a paid for
house yes sir what's this house worth a
1.2 million dollars it's crazy it's
insane how much it appreciated baby
steps Millionaire's house alone just for
the house not counting the other stuff
yes by the time you're not even 40. wow
good for you guys well done well tell us
about your journey what got you started
on all this Ramsay stuff and be baby
steps millionaires before your 40 that's
so cool thank you thank you yeah um so
uh we we got married and uh we kind of
knew about the principles we knew about
Dave Ramsey but we uh we didn't really
follow it to a t so um what really set
us off is when we went through FPU
through our church uh back in uh South
Carolina shout out to Rick and Selena
who helped us out with that that's when
we really got intentional and um we
really started getting down into some
gazelle intensity and uh and really cut
back on a lot of things and thought hey
we're going to pay this thing off and we
we really went for it we're both
military veterans Lauren was in the air
force uh I was active duty
um and now in the reserves over 20 years
of service and so one of our things for
this and I saw a show yesterday I loved
that you were giving away Financial
Peace University veterans hey we need it
so Lauren and I have a huge heart for
military families military mental health
that's what uh kind of the next step of
our life is going to look like and so
part of this was setting that example uh
for other military folks
for other military folks and really uh
saying hey you can do this this program
is for you this program works for a
military family and uh and just being
there to walk with other military folks
through this cool what church was your
FPU in Seacoast Church yes sir charades
are good friends hey yeah yeah they're
great they're good family awesome
wonderful family yeah well welcome guys
this is so cool that's so cool and such
a powerful story I love your passion and
motivation for you know helping military
families it's in the story it's in the
passion that really people experience
that life change that's just awesome so
what would you tell people is the key
like as you're talking to those families
as you have military families listening
what would you tell them yeah absolutely
Lauren and I came up with two words
right uh intentionality and persistence
now you got to be intentional
um you gotta you gotta do the work as
the family last hour said you got to
trust the process right trust the
process and then persistence uh part of
our story was
um you know we kind of were Dave
ramsey-ish for a long time
um you're gonna you're gonna fail on
your budget right your budget's gonna
come through and you're not going to be
where you want to be you got to get back
up it takes you know three months to get
that wired down and even after that
you're you're gonna fail you're going to
fall down um you know be the man in the
arena like Teddy Roosevelt says right be
the man that falls down gets dirty gets
back up and does it again you got to
have that persistence and those two
things combined huge power in that okay
in three and a half years you two are
both high powered
personalities during that three and a
half years there had to be at least one
really good money fight
[Laughter]
yeah so I will say that we we had a big
project we want to do to the house I'm
like well you know we can we have a
really low interest rate let's just
let's do the house now but you know you
really like he said we when it came down
to it we really wanted just to Bear down
and focus and stick to the plan stick to
the process and I'm really glad we did
so who was stirred up about the remodel
you that was me because you're real
estate agents you're looking at houses
all day long seeing all this cool stuff
yeah it's worth this now but but it will
be worth even this much more if we do
this Pro yes and you're seeing the cool
stuff every day it'll mess it'll mess
you up I mean it's like test driving a
car I mean it's awesome yeah yeah we
wanted to pray to homes the other day
and my wife is like I'm like no you
can't
so there was a little bit of duking out
about the remodel now or remodelator you
know we're actually that's the next
thing that we are currently I mean the
original back there that's where the
disagreement was yes yes yes correct so
she she saved you yeah she pulled you
out of the fire man hey that was pretty
cool
she owned it and it's perfect well done
touchdown I like it you guys are fun
because I could tell though that you
both are getting it and um that's
there's the gazelle intensity came easy
to you because you applied to a lot of
areas of your life you've got the
military discipline the
um physical discipline you're a trainer
you know you said you do that you love
doing that on the side and um so there's
all of those things come into play with
this and it all applies it's the same
mental muscle that you're using that you
use to do this man I'm so proud of y'all
well done how do you feel to not have a
payment in the world did it freak you
out it was fine yeah it was very weird I
was like we don't have a mortgage
anymore this is crazy it's it still
really hasn't sunk in for me even though
I mean we know we did it we're so proud
we did it but every yeah it's very
freeing for sure will you ever go back
no no no no no no no way now we're free
yeah it's uh I mean you talk about all
the time it is more it's physically
freeing right with the income and stuff
like that more than that much more than
that it's mentally freeing the the
switch that you can't really quantify or
put into words is just an unbelievable
thing you walk different you talk
different
um uh you know your confidence the way
the way you interact with your kids with
your co-workers it permeates through all
these things it's just fantastic wow I'm
so proud for y'all way to go good stuff
and give my friends your pastors a hug
when you see them for me I will yeah
yeah all right we got a copy of Total
Money Makeover for you to give away baby
steps millionaires probably give that
away since you already are one yeah way
to go and Financial Peace University
you've already been through it
membership so you got a lot of give it's
the live and give bundle for you it's
the give and give bundle let's bring up
the kiddos and introduce them what are
their names and ages all right we got
Sophia she's our Soccer Star she's eight
years old we got Gabby our gymnast
all right hey you paid off your house
you got your other numbers right
Lauren do that right I should let Lauren
do that one come on dad that's fun well
done you guys well done we're so proud
of you so proud for you uh live like no
one else later you could live and give
like no one else Noah and Laura and
Sophia Gabby and Caleb Charleston South
Carolina 645
000 paid off house and everything house
is worth over a million did it in three
and a half years making 100 to 300 and
uh baby steps millionaires in the
process count it down let's hear a debt
free screen
[Music]
[Applause]
I love it
man they're impressive
that was incredible folks every time you
hear someone do the debt free scream
like this uh at some point they had a
moment where they said I've had it and
they did that they said you know okay we
were ish and we went no we're done we
make too much money to sit here on a
stupid mortgage we're getting rid of it
you have to control what you can control
you want to do what they did go through
Financial Peace University it's the
proven step-by-step plan it is the
process that you submit yourself to
nearly 10 million people have gotten out
of debt learning how to budget build
wealth be unbelievably generous start
Financial Peace University at
ramseysolutions.com
FPU
ramseysolutions.com
FPU Seacoast Church that they go to is a
wonderful Church we've spoken down there
many times and done our events down
there and all kinds of things there in
Charleston with them and uh it's a
second generation uh Pastor
the current Surat generation is the
second generation doing and they're
wonderful wonderful family wonderful
pastors and it's a big church really
successful very well run very well done
good stuff you guys I love it I love it
I love it this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
scripture of the day First Corinthians
15 58 therefore my dear brothers and
sisters stand firm let nothing move you
always give yourselves fully to the work
of the Lord because you know that your
labor in the Lord is not in vain
Billie Jean King said Champions keep
playing until they get it right
roderick's with us in Houston Texas hey
Roderick welcome to the Ramsay show
hey David Christina thanks for taking my
call sure what's up so
my wife and I are on baby step three and
last year my job promised me a twenty
thousand dollar bonus of us stayed on
that was supposed to be getting this
month uh but now I think there's a
chance I might be getting fired later
this week so when I talked to my boss
I'm trying to figure out how do I
convince them to still give me the bonus
uh why are you getting fired
well uh I'm new at the roll uh the
reason I'm getting the bonuses in the
first place is because they're laying
off part of the department I work in uh
but instead of laying me off they gave
me a promotion and I'm coming on too
slow
um they want me to be a little bit
better I've had a conversation with my
boss in August
I'm saying that he wasn't happy with my
performance
um he said I had until October to get
better just had a conversation with him
last week still not happy and now I've
got a meeting tomorrow so I think he
might be putting the trigger on fire me
I'm sorry that's scary
so you're asking how to get them to give
you the 20K anyway even though you
didn't work out in the role
uh the I stayed on so I could get it
finish up baby step three and I actually
was gonna leave
um since they were laying us off but
they agreed to give me a 20K if I stayed
um but if I get fired obviously I won't
get it okay so
the transition to the new way of doing
things when it's done is when they owe
the money it was scheduled to be in
October but it's taking longer to get
things how they want it so they've
extended that through December so I
would need to stay through the end of
December to get the money
what is the line for when things are
done like is it is it a very clear line
of Project based thing or is it just
kind of something a bit subjective that
the bosses have decided
no it's whenever the the Outsource we
were Outsourcing the work so whenever
the new company takes over to work
that's when they're going to pay out the
bonus but they have a deadline of
December 31st gotcha okay how big a
company is this
a couple billion a year okay all right
um I don't think there's a
perfect sentence or three
that's going to cause a couple of
billion a year company to decide to give
you money if they've already decided not
to
so I don't think I have that key on my
key ring that I could loan to you
um what I what I would do is
Finish Well
and uh it uh
it doesn't sound like it sounds like
they moved you into a role and then did
not give you the support to cause you to
grow into the role instead just stood
you over there on an island and then
they're shocked that the island is
sinking it sounds like leadership's
piss-poor to me but I mean the way
you're describing this
if we were confronting you about not
performing here you would have heard a
lot more than two conversations since
August
and we would have been saying what can
we do to come alongside you and teach
you to ride this horse because
apparently you keep falling off of it
and we want to maybe it'll get you on
the side in the saddle and stay there
and we would be talking about that and
then if you just kept falling off anyway
we you would have known it wouldn't be
any question you're usually when someone
is leaving here they're positive
that the next meeting they're gone
because it's been like a whole bunch of
discussion up to that point so that's
what's bothering me about this and
that's what makes me think there's
nothing you can really say to these
folks what I always do in any
negotiation is and that's what this is
uh if he says you're gone you say
um okay thank you for letting me try
this and I'm sorry that it didn't work
out
um I gave it my all but I just did I
didn't do it I'm not really even in
disagreement with you I'm ready to move
on I was ready to move on back then you
guys asked me to stay and offered me 20
000 to stay
um and you know just retell the story
but it's all you know they own it in
other words don't blame them and then uh
and then just say okay so what do you
guys have in mind as Severance given
that I stayed
because you were going to give me 20 000
extra
is that in the severance
and they go oh yeah yeah we're going to
give you four months and we're going to
give you the twenty thousand dollars and
go okay
right and thank you that's very generous
of you I appreciate that uh or if they
say no you don't get the 20 000 you
would say
um
well you know
you promised it to me if I stayed and I
stayed and I didn't quit you're asking
me to leave so are you sure that you
can't do something about that and I just
asked questions
about that and uh under you know I've
always heard under the underneath the
negotiation if you just have this
underneath the words you're saying if
you'll have this phrase running in your
mind that says no matter what they say
you in your mind you're going that's not
good enough
that's not good yeah that's not good
enough that's not good enough and so
what I learned to do is never get in a
back and forth on the number so we meet
in the middle you know you know I'm
gonna show you the car for twenty
thousand no it's twenty four thousand
we'll meet in the middle of 22. and uh
when when you know when I say 24 and you
say 20 I don't say let's meet the middle
I say that's not good enough
and then I let you squirm
and so I kind of want you to throw a
across the tennis ball back across the
desk at him and say that's not good
enough in some manner of speaking and
that could be it could sound like hey
um you know the 20 000 was really
promised and I stayed
and I was willing to stay
and help you guys get this through I
understand that I didn't do it the way
you wanted it done and that you've made
a decision and I'm not questioning your
decision but I stayed
so is there anything we can do with the
twenty thousand see that's another way
of saying that's not good enough you
follow me and so I but yeah but I think
you own it I don't think you blame
anybody I don't think you uh are are
nasty or unkind or like you guys are
Crooks or something like that because I
don't think they are I think you're
right I think they have the right to
fire you and and they they have the
right to not pay you this
um
and uh depending on the circumstances
around here would we pay that maybe
maybe not it would depend on the
circumstances more than we can get to in
the radio call here
so do you think if if they don't fire
him tomorrow let's say they just call
him in tomorrow and it's just another
meeting where they're like we're
disappointed
um do you think he should start looking
for a new job oh yeah okay yeah
um I got a feeling December 31st they're
all going bye-bye anyway as soon as I
get this handed off to the Outsource it
sounds like it's I think the writing's
on the wall but the other thing is if
they don't fire Miss I'd be asking a lot
of questions about asking okay I get it
that I'm not doing this the right way
what can uh you know can some of you
guys come alongside and teach me and
show me and model for me give me some
support on this and show me how to do
this because my job as the leader when
I've got a team member uh you know
facing
crap is uh I'm my job is to take out
some of their blockers
and as if their blocker is themselves
it's to add some tools to their tool
belt uh show them how to do it and uh
sit with them till they do it and walk
them through that and so uh uh you can't
just go
Um run faster you know I don't know how
to run run faster but I don't know how
to run run faster you know that's that
doesn't work you know it's just and it's
like that's not that's not leading
that's Corporate America crap and it
sounds like that's what you're dealing
with dude I'm sorry sorry you're facing
that you gotta have a little knot in
your stomach going in there in the
morning that's kind of scary but you
know the interesting thing is when you
get home tomorrow night you'll find out
they fired you they didn't kill you hmm
and your life goes on that's your point
your life goes on and you know I was
getting ready to leave anyway so the
only question is whether I get this 20K
and
um you know we always talk about when
you're out of debt and you have your
emergency fund and they walk in and go
uh well we're gonna have to lay you off
and like oh good how much is the
sufferance I was getting ready to go
open a business and kick y'all's butt
anyway so well let's give us a severance
let's get him a copy of paycheck to
purpose by Ken Coleman oh good yeah I
want to hear his his voice like be
excited when he talks about his job
because even right now even if he gets
this job if he continues in this job
he's just it doesn't sound like he's
gonna love it that's a crummy
environment yeah let's get him something
he loves the job he's passionate about
yeah we'll send you a paycheck to
purpose let's get going
that puts the shower of the Ramsey Show
in the books thanks to Austin Ben Zach
Andrew and James in the booth the booth
dudes we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsesolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
foreign
[Music]